is there anything you remember now
looking back on it ah yes here was a bit
of wisdom that I gleaned on one of these
trips that I wouldn't have known
otherwise is there anything you can
point to and say ah that piece of wisdom
or no was it just kind of a feeling of
wisdom no I think it was just more of
just a different mindset it was like
just a different level of Consciousness
that when I was in that place everything
made sense so it's like it was all and
it's like the funny thing about
hallucinogens is like a lot of the stuff
you forget it's like you're here and
then it like leaves you and that's why
people keep oh you know I need to go do
another Retreat I need because it's like
I know it was great and I know I learned
a lot yeah I just don't remember
anything I learned yeah and you take
some of it with you you'll take like one
or two things and then the rest is
forgotten and um so that's what it was
it was like like in an example was like
I always would walk away with this
feeling of like I need to be a better
person like it would crush my my ego and
Crush my my pride